für max und herzlich willkommen zu einer
runde games vier zusammen mit sk wir
machen eine kleine challenge heute ich
bin normalerweise kein zweifel games die
haben wir auch bei meinem bruder schon
auf dem kanal gemacht mein bruder ist
für diejenigen die selten wissen escape
und ja ich darf nur während der
schutzzeit kisten öffnen was passiert
danach
laub dann endet die schutzzeit sobald
sie endete das immer noch okay das aber
noch zählen das ist nur aufmachen wenn
du eine frage von mir richtig
beantwortet diese frage dreht sich um
deine unsere kinder ganz okay alles klar
was haben wir früher immer gemacht wenn
wir uns ganz so gestritten haben und oma
geschimpft hat was hat weder gemacht um
roma zu beruhigen
wir sind die kirche gegangen wir sind
als überraschung so was gekocht oder
gemacht oder gebracht also bei uns
gegenseitig auch uns gegenseitig was zu
tage treten und dann hat dem anderen bsz
brote gemacht
unsere oma hat immer wir haben eine
sache gemacht
die hat unsere oma dann immer gekauft
immer wenn wir daran das ist 80 damals
fast nicht anders spielen kann
jetzt ist ja genau wofür war unsere
aufpasserin damals hielt er immer ganz
besonders bekannt natürlich ist das
könnte ich niemals vergessen die war
immer für also das war so
so eine haushaltshilfe und sie hat aber
auch immer so also in der zeit wo werden
kleine mann hat dann auch immer auf uns
aufgepasst und sehen macht die besten
pfannkuchen der welt warum sie sich bis
heute die pfannkuchen romantisch oder
wenn du siehst und ästhetische fast 90
ja man zu crazy recht heftig und ich bin
schon 20 8 durchscheint
trotzdem es ja dann auch raus junge lies
combo weiter um deren verlauf in china
können nicht erpressen was zum fix damit
ist willkommen zur nächsten runde wir
probieren das ganze nochmal aber sowieso
steht hier natürlich mehr die challenge
bzw die erzählung im vordergrund sollten
sie zumindest und deshalb für mich
weniger wichtig ob ich jetzt gewinne
oder so deshalb wenn wir diese runde
noch machen mal schauen was daraus wird
auch niemanden hinter ihr direkt am
rhein hat nur eine kiste bekommt stefan
sie weiter als wir haben damals im
ersten stock zimmer gehabt den dreh ist
eine etwas auf es ist wieder die selbe
uhren dann haben wir uns im gang mit
irgendwelchen sachen flaschen oder
spielzeug figuren so pfosten aufgestellt
welche sportart die man selbst
ausgedacht hat mal wieder gespielt da
oben die die hieß ich weiß genau was wir
hatten dieses seil das blaue hab doch
gesagt wir haben uns tore aufgestellt
wehrmann tofu sie haben wir gespielt ja
aber wie
hier fließt das wasser weil zu tun wir
hatten auch immer dieses blaue sei dann
haben wir alles gemacht haben irgendwie
haben wir für sie gespielt so geschlagen
wir die sache sowieso geschoben flur
fußball auf den kopf fiel
maximal einen meter breit ist die lage
schon komplett im tor auf einem meter x
5 meter flug bei dem lied das war der
wahnsinn und mit unserer kleinen
schwester die ist ja ordentlich jünger
als wir und mit der sind wir dann immer
mit fat boys über den flur gerutscht und
haben uns drauf geworfen
aber das nicht so lange her deshalb
zählt es nicht aber hast du noch eine
frage parat
ja habe ich was war damals immer unsere
größte sorge wenn wir da oben gespielt
haben was dürfte auf gar keinen euro hat
das nicht vergessen
also es war nicht unsere größte sorge
sind die größte sorge unserer mutter
also das müsst ihr euch vorstellen
das ist echt so eine idee so richtig
großes hühner aus glas meter hoch sowohl
der ultra teure lampe und unsere mutter
gesagt macht ihn nicht kaputt macht ihn
nicht kaputt
jedes mal holz heraus können ja jetzt
noch eine frage jetzt langsam komme ich
dem fahrrad ist weil mir die guten
fragen 1 alles klar
die frage lautet was haben wir damals
zusammen im keller gebraut stinkbomben
und wie mit wie hat man ist total nicht
tomaten war das nicht vor allem dein
werk die stinkbomben dem schwert
verflucht
aber es war ein gemüse wasser drin war
kannst du erklären wie wir es gemacht am
besten kann er den boden
da kann ja nichts wir haben wir haben
uns einfach alle möglichen sachen wir
doch zu einer gewürfelt wasser wir damit
gemacht dass das ganze auch beantworten
also wie hat mit ihren wir die an den
wald versteckt und so von derselben
sache ich glaube schon
liebe im keller gebrautem im waschkeller
von oma
es war aber bibeln
ja er zwiebeln nicht gesagt ich meine
ich meine tomaten haben
wie also was hat sie dazu gebracht zu
stinken
ganz einfach wasser zwiebeln
ja und dann das stehenlassen schimmel
lassen ja genau war das nächste frage
man weil für die frage mich schon
geantwortet anstellen auch eine wir
haben so eine grüne tannen artige hecke
im garten wie nennt man wohl auflaufen
film karotte waren da drin
der zweite lauf weiter möglich frage
brauche dringend eine box frage
freigeschaltet
ich muss jetzt sofort die secret
ausprobieren
die leute vielleicht noch nicht alles
denn hier oben also der landrat
schwertner also da muss man aufpassen
mussten wir den knopf weiter womit haben
wir damals immer versucht was zu bauen
konnte
bauen bauen womit halle gebaut diese
nicht der erde mäßig sein damit das
kleine kinder
der computer läuft dein leben eine
sackgasse aber sieht er sich nicht
jetzt zieht er sich gleich hinter der
verfluchte freunde nein ich will nicht
sterben stelle noch fragen vielleicht
kann sie mich retten
gebastelt mit krepppapier nein im keller
wieder gut habe ich früher im keller
gebastelt wann ich welche material kost
als material weiß nicht was du meinst
holzinger geschehen wer mit holz ding
gebaut ich habe drei jahre warten die zu
aktivieren ok wusste ich muss sie echt
nicht klein laubsägen da irgendwas
gebauter ach so doch ok wieder am leben
ok dann auch noch mal raus blogs
ach ja genau was hat damals jetzt neue
ausländerfeindlichkeit dieser einer
deiner kollegen triton war dass diese
geschichte ja so ein kumpel ihr alter
sack wird gleich war 9 und wir hatten in
unserer also wir hatten in unserer stadt
so ein bisschen problembezirk sag ich
mal und davon waren auch ein paar kinder
bei uns in der klasse und mit denen habe
ich auch gespielt sowohl als kind
unterscheidet man nicht jetzt auch nicht
dies das aber grundsätzlich ohne
vorurteile auf jeden fall war der typ
hat bei mir gespielt und habe einfach
meine ec-karte ich hatte da schon in ca
seit etwa der auffassung dass wir das
halt relativ früh haben sollen dass wir
damit umgehen lernen hat die einfach
geschnitzt er dafür gerade mit neun
jahren das netz wandern bei der banken
hat gefragt wie viel er damit abheben
kann
für die lange erzählen zwei kisten
öffnen oder einfache frage und antwort
geben
ok mal gespannt ob ich was klären kann
hier in kassel waffe okay sind dann
unterliegen kann ich eigentlich nicht
schnell wenn er sagt jetzt kannst du
denn wenn er wieder vor gericht gegeben
hat hat sich eine ausgeloggt hier
trotzdem wissen ich gebe dem rücken
jetzt kann dieses netz der andere stabil
ich müsste noch gut geben weil er hat
mir ein schwert gegeben ich glaube er
weiß dass youtube wäre normal natürlich
ja das wird über davor schon geschrieben
an nick pilz ich das mal für ihn wenn er
so freundlich war ohne ihn hätte ich dir
und und niemals weitergeführt aber die
change war wieder richtig lustig wenn
ein paar andere sachen müssen wollt
schaut mal vorbei auf seinem channel
sechs kammern abonniert das bringt doch
tatsächlich abonnieren sk abonnieren
bringt definitiv abonniert den kleinen
finger zu schauen
locker dessen locker drei leute und 4
er schreibt jetzt mal gespannt ob ich
habe schreibt jemand sorry es ja ich
habe die runde gar nicht mitgespielt
das mag ich nicht wer macht dann dauert
es immer drei jahre länger alter mann
ist verboten
ach nein
die einheit habe okay das war nur
lustige runde ich bin erst mal schnell
dass es nicht viel zu lang wird bis
dahin macht gut und tauscht aber es geht
vorbei abonniert es so wie er es gerne
wollte